greed corp investira 500 millions de
dollars pour moderniser des
installations de la fonderie horne le
plan prévoit une baisse progressive des
émissions d'arsenic au cours des cinq
prochaines années pour atteindre
l'objectif fixé par québec la compagnie
admet cependant qu'il n'ya pas de
solution sur la table pour atteindre la
norme provinciale de 3 nanogrammes par
tous à rouyn noranda présentement le
projet qu'on présente aujourd'hui nous
amène au 15 novembre tel que mentionné
par le ministre de l'environnement plus
tôt cette semaine mais c'est certain
qu'on arrête pas là vaut toujours
constitué avoir amélioré les
performances cette annonce n'a pas
rassuré ce médecin urgentologue de rouyn
noranda qui auraient souhaité des
actions plus rapides ont fait un
compromis pour avait un compromis ça va
nous prendre 5 un prêt à faire quelque
chose de compromis vous maniez faut être
sérieux la santé des gens c'est pas
juste ce n'est pas juste des mots faut
que les investissements se fassent
rapidement pour qu'on arrive à 15
beaucoup plus rapidement que le député
de québec solidaire et mélissa à
therrien a l'impression que la fonderie
horne et le gouvernement caquistes se
sont entendus derrière des portes closes
pour déterminer la cible à atteindre
l'on est dans une optique ou le lac est
sans me le dire ben dites nous de
combien vous pouvez diminuer de
pollution c'est ce qu'on vous demande
pour françois legault le plan proposé
répond aux exigences de la santé
publique à 15 9 g la santé publique dit
c'est sécuritaire
et on est à l'étape de consulter la
population à la ville de rouyn noranda
la mairesse aurait voulu un plan plus
précis à long terme on peut comprendre
qu'avec un délai supplémentaire mais on
aurait aimé voir se plaint ou avoir des
informations sur ce plan à long terme
pour l'atteindre straw nanogrammes
le syndicat des employés de la fonderie
horne accueille toutefois ce plan avec
soulagement puisqu'il met fin à une
période d'incertitude où il y avait des
inquiétudes le cours leur emploi c'est
évident surtout quels ministères pilot
ministre a été été assez clair là dessus
alors qu'il tentait pas une fermeture
possible la direction de glencore dit
être en pourparlers avec le gouvernement
du québec pour obtenir une aide
financière dans le cadre de ce projet de
transformation sans toutefois vouloir
s'avancer sur un chiffre précis ici marc
andré landry radio canada rouyn noranda